[Musique]
edouard ce mois qu'il est baptisé
doivent trop dix ans et que je montrais
doit à des paris sur celui là c'est
crocus suicidaire montre 3,1 peut et
doit mieux faire c'est pour la bonne
cause c'est pour celle des chats vous
avez toujours aimé les chats et les
animaux j'ai bien sûr c'est toujours
vécu avec un chat sur mes filles sauf
quand je tournais train je joue au
théâtre ils m ont dit que vous êtes un
vieux philosophe vis-à-vis les gens et
vis-à-vis des vis-à-vis des animaux oui
d'accord je crois que pour accepter
d'avis actuelle il faut beaucoup de
philosophie pour conserver sa bonne
humeur et nous pensaient que les animaux
les chats par exemple représente un peu
ce côté fille sauf
oui parce que ils sont équilibrés oui et
des animaux de races différentes qui
vivent ici depuis compter que j'avais
avant durera 6 bat il n'y a jamais eu de
déclaration de guerre
ses parents se chamaillent mais on ne va
pas fou par les trois-quarts de l'argent
l'un des engins de destruction et vivent
leur vie jusqu'à leur mort ils profitent
de la vie ce sont des hédonistes du fui
la douleur alors que l'homme semble à
rechercher l'homme pourrait être heureux
sur cette planète ne s'y limiter les
bêtes c'est facile
[Musique]